[Musique]
il est temps que la
communauté internationale comprenne que c'est un
problème qui doit être traité maintenant
sinon nous allons transformer une situation de
rupture il y aura un niveau élevé d'
insécurité alimentaire aiguë il y aura des millions de
personnes de plus  cela nécessitera une
aide alimentaire et il nous faudra des années pour
contrôler cette situation
[Musique] [
Musique]
um Samaritain Jamie na kama est dr.  laraby
a cabeza de Conti sont vrais tout au long de
l'année mais un accueil extrémiste au
Japon je veux dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le problème que nous avons dans la région est
que la saison de plantation va arriver
très bientôt ça va commencer ça va commencer
Avril Avril Mai dans la plupart des pays,
cela signifie que si nous ne sommes pas en mesure de
contrôler la population de criquets pèlerins pour le moment,
il y aura un impact énorme sur les
plantes à venir
[Musique]